I'm Kat temp I'm here to answer the
internet would you rather have your
internet history made public or a sex
tape that goes viral oh my God sex tape
that goes viral because yeah my internet
history like then people can get mad at
me if the sex tape goes viral then I'm
the victim and I can capitalize yeah
it's also not like I would ever film
anything where I look bad
I'm the victim and I'm famous for it
other than everything
would you would you be like
and everyone would feel bad for me but
then like everyone's seen your [__]
you know what I mean so there is a
trade-off yeah there's a trade-off but I
don't like what you think my [__]
looks like
two buns you can only press one a
instantly get a million dollars be up a
50 50 chance you get 100 million dollars
obviously B 100 million yeah when when
in your life do you think the answer
would have been a like when you were
dartboard you think you would have just
taken the million or do you think you
were always risky I think I was always
I've always been
I've never met a risk at all
would you rather watch your dad [__] 100
year old man or B watch your mother kill
someone watch my mom kill someone
because she's already done so she's
gonna get any trouble
what's worse people who run marathons or
Polar Plunge people
oh I I think people who run marathons
because there's more of them and they
train for it the Polar Plunge they don't
train for us they're like no I can't
come drink with you because I have to
prepare for my Marathon so then they're
also declining on you and making you
feel bad about your own decisions that's
a great answer I know the yeah the polar
plunges yeah you also need to shut up
what would your 12 hour crime spree be
during The Purge man I would have to
hide in the purge look at me like I'm so
rapable and murderable
crimes no I I have to hide what's the
youngest age child that could beat you
up if they have teeth
[Laughter]
I don't know again I don't have kids
when do they grow their teeth I I no
teeth because teeth you're getting at
like
five six no three four like four months
you could you could beat up
a 10 year old I know but I've seen 10
year old boys with bigger boobs than me
what would you trade a three-year-old
baby for I mean like it depends on who
the three-year-old baby is totally but
are you getting it or receiving like in
your mind is it my three-year-old baby
where's your mind go when you first read
it are you getting rid of it you're
getting it uh I mean I I don't I don't
know like I don't know why I would have
a three-year-old baby in my possession
I'd be like take this from me
for my life without a three-year-old
baby that's what I would say I'm already
traded maybe that's it
conversation with a firefighter yeah if
you had to eat one human body part what
would it be like consume it yeah like a
pinky toe it's the smallest you're gonna
choose like the bones the very bones
okay maybe like an ass cheek yeah that
would take forever depending on whose
ass it is a small ass cheek would you
rather live in colonial times at the
year 2500 colonial times would be weird
because as a woman I wouldn't be allowed
to have a career I'd have to just do
housework and like I suck at that like
like I don't even yeah so uh probably
the year 2500. colonial times as a man
if I could be a founding
fathers they had a pretty good start
yeah if you only had five dollars to get
drunk what would you buy I wouldn't eat
all day and then I would buy two 40s of
malt liquor yeah that'll do it if you
were taking hostage five years ago what
would surprise you most about the world
today five years that I married
[Laughter]
you get get [__] faced any U.S president
who would it be I feel like I'd have to
say George Washington because he would
have all the tea but I bet like Grover
Cleveland would be more fun Grover
Cleveland
that has uh nobody has ever answered
that in the history of this show Rover
Cleveland why is he fun because I think
he was more of anything goes kind of guy
right oh yeah okay all right would you
rather ever be naked all the time or
clothed all the time oh definitely
clothes all the time people leak
is that obviously
that was one of the grossest statements
I've ever heard in my life people leave
don't shoot the messenger
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out